أجنبي
يذهب إلى العمل تحت الأرض مع فرونت لاين ديفندرز
الأوكراني ضد
الشركة العسكرية الروسية الخاصة الوحشية
مجموعة فاجنر أندريه
وباريستيك يقولون إنهم يقاتلون جنود
واغنر ستورموترز كل يوم تقريبًا
هذا ما كان عليه الحال عندما
تعرضت حفنة من قواتهم للهجوم
من قبل حوالي 200 مقاتل فاغنر
كنا نقاتل أه  لحوالي 10 ساعات
متتالية ولم يكن الأمر وكأنه مجرد موجات
كانت
بلا انقطاع ، لذا كان الأمر كما لو أنهم
لم يتوقفوا عن المجيء ،
يقول أندريه إن رجله أخذ عشرات من
جنود فاغنر حتى اضطروا هم أنفسهم إلى
التراجع عن
140 منهم 80 كانوا  جريحًا ومقتل 60 شخصًا
وكانت فصيلتي 13 شخصًا
بالإضافة إلى العديد من المشاة ، كانت حوالي
20 جنديًا من جانبنا وأه
لا دعنا نقول 200 من جانبهم
تكتيكات فاغنر يقول إنهم يحاولون
التغلب على الأوكرانيين بإرسال
موجات من المقاتلين  جُنِّدوا المحكوم عليهم
خارج السجن مباشرة إنهم أه
جعلوا المجموعة لنفترض أن من 10
جنود يمرون 30 مترًا ثم
بدؤوا بالحفر والاحتفاظ
بالموقع المجموعة التالية قادمة
30 مترًا يصلون إلى موقعهم
ويذهبون بعد 30 مترًا أيضًا أه
المكسب وهذه هي الطريقة التي يحاولون بها خطوة بخطوة
للمضي قدمًا ،
يقول الأوكرانيون إن مقاتلي Wagner غالبًا ما يبدو أنهم خدروا
المدفع الرشاش كان على وشك
الجنون لأنه كان يطلق النار عليهم
وقال إنني أعلم أنني أطلق النار عليه لكنه
لم يسقط
ثم بعد مرور بعض الوقت ربما كان
ينزف منه بالفعل ، لذا فهو يسقط فقط
أه يبدو أنه من المحتمل جدًا
أنهم يحصلون على بعض المخدرات قبل
مهاجمتهم ، زودتنا الوحدة
بتسجيل يقولون إنه لأندريه
يستجوب فاجنر المأسور  مقاتل
أجنبي ، لقد
تواصلنا مع رئيس Wagner يفغيني
مقدمة حول مزاعم إساءة المعاملة في
صفوفهم ، كانت هذه إجابته على
حساب Wagner على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هنا CNN يكتب ، هل تعتقد حقًا
أننا سنناقش قضايانا العسكرية
معك بينما تكون منفتحًا  العدو
هو نفسه مناقشة
الأمور العسكرية ومشاركة المعلومات مع
وكالة المخابرات المركزية. يقول أندريه بغض النظر عن عدد
المقاتلين الذين ألقوا عليهم قبلهم ، فإنهم
سيقاومون هذه هي الحرب من أجل الحرية ، إنها
كلمة للديمقراطية ، نعم
إنها ليست كذلك بالنسبة لي.  حرب
بين أوكرانيا وروسيا لكن هذه
حرب بين نظام
أه الديمقراطية
وبالتأكيد يقول الأوكرانيون
إنهم لن يتنازلوا عن شبر واحد من
الأرض دون قتال ولكن
الأمور بالنسبة لهم تزداد
صعوبة أيضًا لأنهم الآن يقولون  إنهم
لا يواجهون شركة Wagner العسكرية الخاصة فحسب ،
بل إنهم يواجهون أيضًا
الوحدات الروسية العادية وكذلك نسخة طبق الأصل من CNN
pakrofsk Ukraine